[Musique]
quelle est la valeur de ce que l'on
pêche dans le saint laurent même si les
captures fluctue d'une année à l'autre
la valeur des prises au débarquement
dans les ports du québec est d'environ
275 millions de dollars par année
le crabe le homard et la crevette
représente la plus importante part des
prises de la province les poissons de
fond et les poissons pélagiques comptent
pour moins de 10% de la valeur des
pêches la gaspésie et la région où les
débarquements sont les plus importants
suivent les îles de la madeleine la
côte-nord et le bas-saint-laurent au
total cette activité génère près de 3700
emplois saisonniers